[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream 131 q and a segment
beginning
now
excellent
we have two questions from our discord
server this week every week
they ask questions amongst themselves
and i actually don't know exactly what
the rubric is but uh we they vote and
they give us one we got two this week
i'm allowed to choose uh they're both
really really good and we didn't have a
q a last week so we may just do both of
them even though we got a lot of great
questions coming in with a q a system as
well what point of order
grammatically shouldn't it be the
discordant server no
no
no apparently no no no
um
i mean i think you just don't get to
change the name of an established
product that someone else owns
i don't
wait you could try tomorrow it's
father's day
every day is father's day brett right
which is why i get to change the name of
established things if i want um
how well is that working out for you not
not well yet but i think when people
realize you think once compliance is up
along with morale everything will be
better
it seems like a very uh simple model of
of men especially fathers that you have
there not inaccurate you applied the
simple model of men and we're trying to
force everyone to adopt it because
that's what men do right that's what men
do right exactly
all right okay okay man the first
question is for you from the discord
server what's your evolutionary opinion
about bras
are they helpful harmful or both why do
we have them
like
wait yeah no it is actually the question
it is yeah
bras and bras like the uh
the the the breast restraining device
not the not like hey bro
they didn't oh they presumably did spell
it but i haven't seen their spelling so
how would i know yeah yeah um
interesting actually intro i hadn't
really given this much much thought
one of the places my brain went that it
wouldn't have 10 years ago or 30 years
ago was
as compared to like chess binders
right
so just binders are bad for you these
are what um
what people women girls
who are thinking of transitioning to
becoming
trans boys or trans girls
wrap around their chest in order to
flatten their breasts in order to pass
as boys or men
and those are understood to have um bad
bad health effects how could they not
really how could they not how could they
not
but
i do think that there have been
similarly that there have been bras in
the past that have been very tight
uh and that especially if you've got an
underwire situation going on and it's
not very well made and you know i i
think it could have similarly
bad effects on respiration and on even
like you know muscle
muscle health
um
where you know where they are um
i think
you know it's i haven't honestly given
this that much thought but it
i do wonder
and i don't know if anyone has tried to
reconstruct it and my first guess is how
would you could there possibly be any
data on this but it does feel to me like
the incredibly large diversity in breast
size
that we have in weird countries now
is a more or less modern phenomenon that
there has been a lot of variation in
shape and to some degree size and
definitely you know firmness and these
things obviously change over time and
once you breastfed and all of these
things are true pretty reliably so but
the really great diversity in size is
probably about um
eating a lot of garbage frankly um at
some level like that you know the
hormones in our you know the rbsd and
such in our food and
and such and so
you know really large breasted women
are very uncomfortable without being
able to to put on bras and i don't know
to what degree that would have been a
problem
10 000 years ago my guess is it wasn't
nearly as much of a problem on the other
hand it's very much more comfortable
if you're doing active things
to have a harness on
yeah my instinct is exactly the same
that we have a uh
an effect not only i mean there is the
rbst thing but there's just the symptoms
the the
synthetic bovine growth hormone that
gets put into a lot of dairy right um
but there's also just the fact of us
being anomalously sized
by virtue of of uh
nutrition which would have been limiting
for all of our ancestors that just
simply isn't limiting for us and so uh
allometric things unfold that wouldn't
and
because breasts are
the unique thing about human breasts is
that they persist
when a woman is not lactating unlike any
other mammal and so that's because they
have become an advertisement presumably
of having the resources to be capable of
producing an offspring they're an
advertisement of fertility effectively
and um because so fertility would be
limited in ancestor much of the time
by several things by
being pregnant by lactating or in many
cases simply not having enough resources
so the body
turns off the reproductive capacity when
resources are uncertain enough that the
body calculates it would be unlikely to
successfully raise an offspring at that
moment so far better to conserve the
resources until a moment when things are
more plentiful so why are guys fixated
on these things because they're an
advertisement of fertility which because
our ancestors were faced with women who
didn't have enough to eat
became an honest indicator of something
very very important but now in an
environment where everybody has enough
to eat or almost everybody has enough to
eat um it's an unreliable indicator of
anything important but it has been
augmented because effectively
competition between female ancestors to
broadcast
fertility in a
world where
garnering the right mate made a big
difference in how
successful you were evolutionarily that
system has basically just run away yep
all right let's go with their second
question as well
do you have any advice on prepping for
the common common
i'm going to start over do you have any
advice either of us on prepping for the
coming onslaught of food energy food
energy shortages covid civil unrest
tyranny
other than typical advice on prepping
websites thanks trying to see if i've
missed anything
we've all missed something
but um and that's that's obviously a big
big question and you know food shortages
energy shortages covet what exactly
civil unrest
uh civil unrest that is downstream of
food shortages that's downstream of
energy shortages it's downstream of
mandates it's downstream of um
restrictions on you know civil rights
for
uh civil liberties for you know the
dirty and vaccinated
uh civil unrest for because of some new
trumped-up thing that's today's new
thing
you know lots lots of places for this to
go but a lot looks like it's on the
horizon and
how to prepare yeah
um
this is this is a difficult topic um
people's ability to prepare varies
tremendously based on circumstance the
first thing you want to do is look at
where you live
and figure out what
scenarios first of all
if i were you i would surrender on the
absolute worst case scenarios because if
you try to prepare for the absolute
worst case scenarios it will burn
all of the resources that you would then
otherwise be able to dedicate to
mixed scenarios and you probably won't
succeed so great and your life now is a
living hell
right
so um
i would say there's sort of two
categories of intermediate scenarios
fast and slow
breakdown of stuff
a fast scenario is one you need to be
prepared for but it's probably
short-lived because
all the people who didn't prepare
something is going to happen with them
and uh
in a slower scenario the same thing
happens but as peop you know there's
basically a period of time in which
people are catching up and the world is
sorting out between people who can
figure out what to do when they haven't
prepared well and people who can't
um
i do think you know
the problem
for anybody who's asked for advice on
this topic
is
if i thought there was a 30 chance
of a
dramatically bad but survivable
breakdown of civilization in the next
five years
i'm not saying i do or i don't but if i
thought so
and i say well you should prepare
obviously if there's a 30 chance of such
a thing you should prepare on the other
hand the chances that it doesn't happen
and it seems like you know
the sky is falling
is pretty high and so
there's a credibility question how high
does the danger of such a thing have to
be before it's worth preparing and i
would say that number is
pretty low right it's worth you know if
you have a family
it's more or less your obligation to
prepare
even if there's a 10 percent chance of a
really bad but survivable scenario
um
so
i i i don't wanna i don't wanna go too
far down this road because it will
become
it will become ammunition but you know
look at your life figure out what you
can do without
don't undervalue
people
you want to be partnered with people
trying to survive alone based on good
preparation isn't going to be anywhere
near as useful as gathering with other
people and
pooling your insights and
um you know agreeing to
team up
uh
don't undervalue the hazard that
desperate people pose to whatever plan
you've got
right if things go really bad
your biggest problem is going to be that
no matter what you've planned those who
haven't planned are
going to be in a dire circumstance and
people
are not what you have become accustomed
to when they are starving
so things like that
okay
next question
what is your opinion on the safety of
weekly kova testing using swabs
sterilized with ethylene oxide a known
toxin and carcinogen
any eto remnants that's the ethylene
oxide on the suave are supposedly within
safe limits but might
but my weekly exposure in the nose over
years be hazardous my university
requires it of the unvaccinated love you
both
yeah we've heard a lot about within safe
limits about a lot of things over over
the years and
one
always
has to
ask to to begin with on what basis have
you established safe limits and did you
also follow those people through for
decades was there any long term writing
which and they're never it can be
essentially guaranteed won't have
happened in this case and if you dig
you'll find it didn't happen in any case
that's the typical thing but also but i
mean we all we all take in known
carcinogens and toxins in various ways
and so
uh the idea that no you just you never
ever ever take anything like that
no
on the other hand being forced to do so
because university has an insane system
in place and that's what they're gifting
you in exchange for putting up with you
being dirty and unvaccinated
is is
seems a bit unacceptable
well i would say you've got a bunch of
systems that protect you from the
general toxin carcinogen issue right
some level you're depending on that
there's certain things that you
shouldn't take in any of
right
lead and mercury right these are things
that really don't belong in you and you
don't have a good system for dealing
with them and the consequences are
serious
um
so
my guess is i don't know anything about
this compound actually so i don't know
what's in it but um but my guess is it's
a standard toxin and a small amount of
it is something you will detoxify and be
all right
but weekly testing could you roll the
dice badly and end up with a cancer sure
on the other hand you're not exactly
free of that risk just running around
breathing you know as you're if you're
driving down the highway yeah and you've
got the vent open you're breathing a lot
of exotic stuff right yeah it's just
happening
but what i would say is
the exact comparison the very people who
are telling you that this is within safe
limits are the same people who think it
is rational for you to be required to
take this test because you didn't get a
vaccine that doesn't prevent contraction
and or transmission
so they basically announced we are not
interested in logic or we are not good
at it one of the two may maybe both
that's right and this is within safe
limits don't worry about it and my
feeling is you know when somebody says
i'm a flat out [ __ ] and here are some
facts you should be aware of
it's probably not a good package right
yeah and yes they've made it difficult
to fact check their facts but uh it's a
good chance some of their facts aren't
facts
yeah they're not facts
yeah they're not
fact facts yeah they're fact-ish factish
yeah yeah factish
i am happily unvaxed and take a high
dose of hydroxychloroquine daily for
lupus i've had multiple covet exposures
including when my thrice faxed roommate
had covered but i've never gotten it i'm
suspicious it's the hcq
your thoughts p.s grateful to you too
for keeping me from messing with my
already quirky immune system
yeah
highly likely yeah highly likely highly
this is uh you know we we've talked much
less about this um
we missed this one
we missed hcq
when it was first uh being discussed uh
because we didn't pay much attention to
the
the you know the way that it came at us
i i bought their [ __ ] frankly
right well it came wrapped in trump
thinks so
we didn't think not because trump thinks
so but we just thought oh there's all
these people thrashing about looking for
solutions and
i still thought that some of our
authorities were looking for solutions
at that point well and we were focused
on lab leak too going like yeah but that
this seems like almost like a diversion
like i missed it i guess we both missed
it
i bought their [ __ ] and their
[ __ ] was packaged as
uh this looked sort of promising we've
done the work turns out it doesn't work
and what's more it's hugely dangerous
yeah right and i don't know
you know yeah uh i i do sometimes say
no matter
how cynical you are you're still being
naive and so we are always in this
process of learning that our cynicism
was not
strong enough for the waters we were
swimming in this is one of these cases
where
now that i've seen how it worked with
ivermectin and gone back and looked at
how it worked with hydroxy clerk and now
it's a playbook yeah right now and this
matthew 1 t crawford matthew crawford's
uh rounding the earth newsletter on
substance he has gosh he's into very
high roman numerals by now the
hydroxychloroquine wars is i think what
he calls it yeah and he's he he was on
it from the beginning and
i wasn't paying attention to it he
wasn't on the story we don't know that
he was on no yeah i mean he was on the
story he was on the beat um as um
effectively uh figuring out what we
could uh what he could about the science
and about what was being said so the the
inter the interaction of both what is
true about
hcq and its role in both preventing and
treating covet and also what society was
having us believe about it and you know
the particulars are different but it's
very much like ibm like these are the
two these are the two big
drugs that were uh already widely
distributed as you know the person
writing in here says you know they're on
it for lupus yeah widely distributed
well understood to be safe you know
slightly different safety profiles
different mechanisms of action you know
and we don't know as much about hcq
except we've both been on um chloroquine
derivatives um as part of our malaria
prophylaxis in the past
uh and
uh it's
yes
like how
well it's possible there seems to be
some people who just don't get covered
the one reason
is that i don't think we have good
evidence uh that it functions as a
prophylactic well i don't remember
actually i thought it was on it's not on
the floor i guess it's not on the
flccc's prophylactic regimen i don't
think so um
i could be wrong about that but
um the thing is a
chronic treatment for lupus
would be enough of a dose that yeah uh
a
the depending on mechanism mechanism of
action it could very well work as a
prophylactic but even if you didn't
you might end up with a
sub threshold
case that you never knew you had
yeah
so if you think about it a prophylactic
dose is really the ultimate early
treatment
right it's treatment the instant that's
right in the instant you came down with
it
um
or were just exposed
um yeah it's going to take me a little
while to figure out
i don't think it's on here as as part of
their i don't think it is yeah
all right
next question if i can figure it out so
it is recommended but not prophylactic
yeah
and as early as possible sometimes your
exposure even
okay why
do certain animals of the same type who
are usually seen in similar geographic
areas i.e birds doves and crows evolved
to have huge differences in apparent
intelligence
they're
it's a
it's a great question
it's a it's a big question um that
basically has the answer within it at
some level right you're thinking
proximity to television
yeah that's exactly what i'm thinking
about um same type clearly you mean um a
clay to phylogenetic grouping so you say
birds right um that
those things therefore somehow have some
shared history but birds is a giant
ancient group right so
uh there were already birds at the kt
boundaries and they i don't remember
actually at the moment how old birds are
but they're at least older than 65
million years so you can't just do you
know doves and crows and be like well
they must have shared strengths and
weaknesses and therefore
uh we should expect to see them doing
similar things in against similar
geographic areas
micro habitat is real and also similar
geographic area doesn't necessarily
control for are they actually in the
same place so you know a mediterranean
climate
um it's not the same thing as saying
actually they're in the mediterranean
but i'm not even
maybe i misheard the question but it
sounded like the same type
were they talking about con specifics
no dubs versus crows for instance dubs
dubs can you read the question why do
certain animals of the same type who are
usually seen in similar geographic areas
i.e birds colon doves and crows
evolved to have huge differences in
apparent intelligence well that's still
still ambiguous but i agree that that's
the most likely interpretation is that
it's doves compared to crows and then
the yeah so i mean it's a totally
different question if we're talking
right interest specifically which is to
say within a species right inter
specifically
so the the answer
if we are talking about
you know inter-specific between species
between species doves versus crows for
example is going to be a question of the
type of niche and whether it's a
puzzle-solving niche and if it's a
puzzle-solving niche then it requires
what we would recognize as intelligence
and we've all seen
you know crows do
unique things i've seen videos of crows
repeatedly taking
the
top to some bottle and using it to ski
down a roof right this is obviously not
a behavior they inherited genetically
it's something an animal is innovative
but the question is how much of you
getting fed
is the result of you solving a problem
that nobody's seen before that will
result in intelligence and how much of
you getting fed is from some other
characteristic so and this is what i
meant
with the beginning of my answer which is
similar geographic areas is too big a
category
so
it's it doesn't it
that is not enough to explain what an
organism is going to do and i think
here's a place where we tend to
anthropomorphize because humans do
everything everywhere like
we're completely unusual in this regard
there are some other generalists out
there who do a lot of things a lot of
places but no one else does no other
species on this planet
does as much as we do as many places as
we do it
and so
any place you are even if you're a
generalist like a crow for instance you
are going to be figuring out a
particular set of things to do in order
to to accomplish the things that you
need to do which okay at base the things
that you need to do survive and
reproduce are the same across the board
but slime molds do it differently from
cedar trees do it differently from
domestic cats which do a largely very
poor job of reproducing do it
differently from humans right so
uh
it it is much more about niche which is
kind of geographic area
but it's a much more precise
and evolutionarily
explanatory
parameter that is not in the question as
asked yup
uh we already answered that one
you are a chinchilla rancher
if you want larger chinchillas you
selectively breed your biggest animals
if you want faster chinchillas you
select the quickest individuals to breed
but what if the trait you want to
maximize is sexual dimorphism how could
you select which animals to breed
what selects for this
well i don't know that you i mean a
subsumed into your
into your
framework
is the heritability of the
characteristics that you're selecting
for in other words if the largest
animals are largest because
they have inherited proximity to food
but not because size
is genetically heritable then it won't
work
um
so
so part of i mean this is actually very
this fits right in with the mice
breeding protocols thing right like if
you you might end up
being best off
if for some reason you want a highly
sexually dimorphic chinchilla population
not sure what you're up to but okay
you might be best off by producing the
social circumstances
wherein
one male can monopolize the reproductive
efforts of multiple females leaving a
bunch of males sort of reproductively
starving and hungry on the side
wherein that one male feels very much at
threat but he but he they that most of
them don't get to reproduce so that you
provide
the
social and effectively the environmental
situation that will that will produce
polygeny
and then under mating systems that are
strongly pollutionist that is to say one
male multiple females who are passing
their genes into the future generations
leaving out most of the males
that is likely to produce a stronger
sexual
sexual size and possibly strength
dimorphism down the road as well yeah so
i think that's one of two ways you can
either create the conditions that select
for
the thing in question that we know
select for the thickened question right
or you could there's no reason you
couldn't uh breed males and females
whose litters ended up maximally
dimorphic
right you could potentially select for
it directly assuming it's irritable in
that way
yeah assuming it's horrible in that way
uh
and i guess you could do a little bit of
both
again we don't recommend that you do
this at home and we don't know why you
would
yeah
i guess they haven't
if this is your plan
for world domination i would rethink it
yeah you may have to uh
you may not end up dominating the world
right yeah or at least it'll be very
slow going at first using chinchillas
which you are presumably going to ride
into battle or i don't know what but
yeah only the males the now massively
tusked and uh and horned maybe right
males
um yeah yeah i mean you know it's sort
of a prototype of a plan more than a
plan yeah and i guess we didn't i mean
so sexual dimorphism could actually i
said you know faster no i said bigger
stronger but could be you know more
armed which is one of the ways that
sexual amorphism
uh presents so like if you end up
breeding chinchillas that do in fact
have tusks or horns or you know spikes
down their back thus making them more
war
war-worthy
okay then you have succeeded in your
plan at least to produce highly sexually
dimorphic chinchillas but probably not
in your plan to dominate the world which
may in fact be what at least we have
inferred you were trying to do well give
the world a little time to soften itself
up a bit more and uh you know you might
be you might be you might hit the sweet
spot at the point you have you're worthy
chinchillas and the world has grown more
feeble through confusion over
gender and
statistics uh then you know yeah you
might you might be you might be well
positioned
thoughts on the mass release of gmo
mosquitoes to try to control their
population
what could go wrong
um
you know i tend to be
i tend to be less concerned about
there are certain circumstances in which
releasing a gmo animal into the wild is
fraught with danger and there's certain
other places where it's not that likely
to cause a hazard because selection
produces whatever it produces and
effectively
um you know even if your plan failed
this election would revert the thing
back to an ancestral state do you like i
i feel like i ran into that kind of
story for
plausible gmo mosquitoes a while back
and i just haven't thought about it in a
long time do you know anything about i
think these are maybe sterilized males
um
so it prompts it gets mating effort from
females who then don't end up with
fertilized eggs right yeah the eggs are
bored or something like that okay um
yeah it's easier at a technical level um
than castrating male mosquitoes
this complete lack of an intermittent
organ may also be part of the problem
there
right so maybe it's just the external
intestines it wouldn't be yeah that's a
fine grain actually i don't even know i
have no idea how mosquitoes made
um
yeah what parts they have
or don't
right yeah
right
so you think that it's sterilizing
one section like these large batches
that then go out and uh go to the bars
for the other mosquitoes and uh pretend
to be intact because they don't know any
better and thus um block the production
of some number of baby mosquitoes
because uh
the fertile mosquitoes
think no of course they don't actually
think uh but that they've been
if it's females that they've had plenty
of sex they don't need to have anymore
that sort of thing mosquitoes don't
think but they think they do
that's all very anthropomorphic sounding
you know i'm not actually attributing
conscious thought to the mosquitoes but
um well you know look it's totally
possible there's some version of this
that we've never heard of but yes that
was a plan at some point
why it does seem like oh we've
sterilized them and the only thing that
could go back to is they're not sterile
like we thought they were
seems the most likely way that can fail
but
but us mucking about in the genomes of
other organisms and being quite certain
that there's only one way for it to fail
which is to go back to as if we hadn't
mucked about at all that seems pretty
hubristic
um
no i think the hubris is imagining that
you're going to successfully
you know what is the long-term plan
you're going to drive this mosquito
species to zero and if you fail to drive
it to zero as soon as you stop this
program do they
come hurtling back yeah um does it clear
the way for another mosquito i mean
maybe that could be better if you're
getting rid of anopheles mosquitoes in
favor of some alternative mosquitoes but
there are there's hundreds maybe even
thousands of species of mosquitoes many
of which i mean anopheles are famously
vectoring many of the worst diseases but
there's they're not the only ones yeah
is it aedes i think is another genus
that um
that vectors things like
yellow fever and malaria maybe i'm not
sure about that
i thought yellow fever was anonymous but
oh it is but i think it may i think
there may be another genus that is
vectored as well but i'm not i'm not
positive
um
yeah i'm not fond of any of this mucking
about over in gmo space
but i do i do agree that in the past i
have thought of all the of all the gmo
interventions that i've heard this one
seems
um
like it has potential to do the least
harm but also lower potential to
actually solve the problem but i would
also say you know we have a much
great i mean first of all this all
assumes that you and i have understood
what is intended here um but the
much bigger danger is something
that we do without worrying about it
like um
taking uh atlantic salmon and farming
them in the pacific
right this is a this is an invasive
species waiting to happen
um and the danger of that is huge
without altering the animals in question
so
we run all kinds of stupid dangers and
my guess is the intent with the gmo
mosquitoes probably just will fail
yeah
okay
excuse me
how where did my questions go there we
go i have asked this before
but curious if your opinions have
shifted as of late seeing the
relationship between the data the
science and the so-called experts
surrounding covet 19 to drive a specific
narrative
to what degree could this be happening
with regard to global warming i mean
we've covered this yeah we have we think
it is happening with regard to global
warming but that doesn't mean well
we have to be incredibly careful because
we will get
bird at the stake they'll do a cross
something
for errors on this topic
there's no question in my mind and i
think our minds that the academic
environment surrounding the study of
climate change will be unhealthy that
the dangers surrounding models is
particularly acute because the nature of
models is such that you can hide
a lot of nonsense and it can look like
very terrifying data and so basically
the expectation is
if you
publish papers that make climate change
look scary and
imminent
then
that's probably good for your career and
if you publish anything that goes in the
other direction no matter how robust the
work you did it's probably not good
because there's a rahra team spirit
let's get the public on board with
remedies
that said
there are other measures first of all
the underlying
explanation for why we expect climate
change is a result of a change in co2
it's very simple atmospheric chemistry
and very easily established
b
there are measures you can look at like
glacial retreat this is a good
integrative measure of where we are
right it takes it's not
you know yes they ebb and flow um with
the seasons but year from year to year
the fact that glaciers are retreating
tells us something on the other hand
although that doesn't tell us that it's
anthropogenic
no it doesn't tell us that it's
anthropogenic but if you've got a
hypothesis that says hey we're changing
the amount of co2 it ought to trap more
heat and one of the things that is
likely to happen is the glaciers will
retreat and then the glaciers retreat
the point is the burden of proof is on
those who say it's from some other
source which it could be
but
i will say
so as somebody who has in my own
thinking
retreated to yep i believe climate
change is real that it's anthropogenic
not completely but uh significantly and
that it it's a scary possibility why is
it a scary possibility
because of the amount of frozen methane
in the arctic and the point is there's
so much methane frozen
in the arctic that if we reach a certain
threshold that no one on earth knows how
to calculate
we could lose control entirely of where
this thing settles out at a new
equilibrium because so much methane
would be released that the temperature
would start to rise which would melt
further methane which would cause it to
rise and we would settle at some new
place which uh could be catastrophically
bad and the point is the day you crossed
that threshold
it's never going to show up in the paper
we're not going to know that it happened
so we ought to invest very heavily
in not getting anywhere near that
threshold right
the work that suggests that we are in
danger of getting to that threshold is
academically polluted how could it not
be because the academic politics aren't
going to be any better than they were
with covet or any other
controversial topic on which a lot is at
stake
but i will say
i was told that kilimanjaro
would lose
all of its glaciers and it was supposed
to have happened
they have retreated
they're not gone i was also told that we
would have seen an ice-free arctic by
now i've been promised that multiple
times
we haven't seen it so the point
is if we look at measures that say
empirically where are we relative to
what we were told was going to happen
we see one thing
is that a reason for comfort
not really
as far as i know the frozen methane
issue is exactly what we imagine it to
be so the hazard is there
we don't have good baseline data on how
much
of that methane is liberated under
normal circumstances right so we're
forced to guess we see big methane
plumes that are obviously liberated
frozen methane but we can't compare them
to what it looked like 50 or 100 years
ago because nobody took the data
so
is it as bad as they say well it's
probably not happening as fast as they
say or the glaciers would be
more retreated than they are right is it
non-existent nope the glaciers are
retreating um how worried should we be
well extremely if you're interested in
the long-term well-being of
humanity on this planet but and this is
this is contained in everything you've
said
we should also be very worried given i
agree with everything you just said
that there appears to be
no academic science uh
tradition alive at the moment that
allows
for results or conclusions that go in
the opposite direction therefore
how will we know you know just exactly
like we're here with with covid like how
will how would we know
if a new
a new treatment a new thing that they're
gonna call a vaccine was actually
effective how would we know at this
point how would we know
oh as it turns out this measure that we
were using wasn't the best measure to
assess whether or not
um the climate change was going to
progress at this rate um but this other
measured parameter that we weren't using
before seems to be better here's how
we're going to show you all the models
we're going to you know we're going to
we're going to be transparent and we're
going to publish the negative results as
well as the positive results we're going
to let people speak even when they find
things that don't aren't on narrative
then we begin to have a chance of
knowing but at the moment we know that
we cannot trust what people are
asserting that you must believe without
investigation
because really whenever anyone asserts
that you must believe something without
investigating it further you should be
suspicious of them especially when
that's coming from scientists who should
know better and i you know hopefully
many of these people do know better and
they have made a deal with the devil in
order to keep their jobs or something
so um this is another way of saying that
what we talked about in the main podcast
the uh everything being mislabeled as a
result of the
privatization of actual information
uh is
the actual sickness
right and all of the versions of this
where we can't figure out what's true
about covet or climate or any of these
other topics
are the symptoms the many many symptoms
of the same disease and the point is
look
that disease is lethal
right that is a that is a humanity
destroying disease if you let it go too
long you cannot play with technologies
this powerful that function at this
scale with this many people on the
planet and not
have a catastrophic failure
if you've basically disallowed public
spirited science journalism
[Music]
governance etc you can't have that stuff
privatized and expect to survive this
way that's right
all right next question
a california court recently found that
bees qualify as fish
yeah bees fish
so um i saw this and i don't remember
there's something about some old just
like aquatic insects lots some
environmental protection law and uh the
court let me just start because i don't
i don't remember
i i didn't have time i just saw this
question to look it up and figure out
exactly what it was but
what courts are deciding about
interpreting what the intent of an
original law was which is what i think
was going on here
doesn't have to be doesn't have to jibe
with our current understanding of what
reality is in that case and that sounds
like a crazy thing to say but
obviously if a law was made before
modern understanding of say phylogenetic
systematics and i don't i again i don't
know what the law was i don't know when
it was but i did see this story a little
bit when it came out this week i think
um
then a modern court trying to figure out
okay what organisms should be included
in that group say that was that was
trying to be protected should be allowed
to take
a uh a you know sensual auto if you will
you know a very broad understanding of
what was meant originally by the framers
of the law as opposed to whether or not
this is actually true in terms of how we
currently understand our history okay so
that's like the
legal part of this like it shouldn't
it's not
it it actually doesn't help anyone to
mock courts for trying to match up a
current understanding with a former
understanding and then also holding them
to
scientific what we currently understand
to be true about scientific reality in
some cases because you can't do both
simultaneously because they're doing two
things differently yes but then i want
to get to the rb's fish thing yeah can i
give you an example yeah great
so let's say that you
for example make a law that says that uh
it is justifiable to use
deadly force
uh in the protection of a person
okay
and then
somebody tries to use this defense
they have used deadly force uh in the
protection of
a
uh deceased person in a casket
they say well it's a person are you
saying that's not a person that was my
uncle right
um
and the answer is well what did the
court mean or what did the legislature
mean when it made the law that said you
could use deadly force you're saying my
uncle wasn't a person right right and
the answer is uh yeah for these purposes
he's not um right
good perfect um so stuff like that and
you know
the another example about um
tadpoles not being vertebrates uh which
is
when you're deciding what experiments
you need to seek special permission for
tadpoles are not vertebrates well this
this was just the vertebrate care
committee that i had to go through at
the university of michigan many years
ago right but it's not it wasn't some
more general assessment but they you
know i having written up many many many
pages on the
moral legitimacy of my intended uh
experiments on tadpoles was told that
doesn't matter because tadpoles aren't
vertebrates the fact that they would
metamorphose into vertebrates and
therefore that argument makes no sense
was both absurd to me but also made my
job dealing with the bureaucracy much
easier so i accepted right and it's not
yeah you know it's wrong scientifically
it's not wrong at the level of the
committee trying to protect what it's
trying to protect right um exactly all
right so bees and fish so are are bees
fish
bees bees are not fish let's uh let's
just here let's play again
all right first i and then you will name
just a bunch of organisms and the other
one will say fish or not fish all right
okay
fairfax
fish maddie in the corner labrador fish
you
fish cedar tree
not fish oh dragonfly not fish whale
fish oh wow really squirrel fish salmon
fish
yeah coelacanth
fish okay you try me all right uh
potatoes not fish not
fish barnacle
not fish
uh
giraffe fish
uh parrot
fish parrot fish
fish fishy fish
um
petunia non-parody fishy fish petunia
not fish
um morel
that's a mushroom which is not a fish
yeah
uh so
because we're live here i'm not gonna
pull up what i
i should have a simple phytogenic tree
to show and i sure i'm i own it many
times over but i i'm not gonna do it on
air here
basically
all those
vertebrates
that evolved from a fishy ancestor
remain fish because that part of your
history hasn't disappeared
fish are vertebrates fish is a smaller
group than vertebrates therefore
anything that is not a vertebrate is
also not a fish
fish has evolved once
and then there's lots of
things that no longer look like fish but
remain fish at the systematic level like
giraffes and fairfax and you
even me
even still fish
parrotfish and parrots and
other fish are all fish
but insects are
not vertebrates and bees are insects and
bees are not fish and shellfish are not
fish shellfish are not fish nor are they
all that selfish right um so
i want to clean that up there was
there's an element of that i think is
going to be obscure okay i'm sure a lot
of it's going to be obscure frankly if
we say
um
there are two ways of defining whether
something belongs in a biological
category right
when we say is a monkey a mammal we mean
is it descended from the ancestor
of
all the things that we agree are mammals
right and a monkey has to be a mammal
this way
the reason
that a cat is a fish is that sharks are
fish and salmon are fish and if we look
at the branch of the phylogenetic tree
that contains sharks and salmon it
contains all of the tetrapods
and so the point is those are fish
because when we say is something a
mammal
we're asking a phylogenetic question
it's different than if we say
our
parrots warm-blooded right parrots are
warm-blooded mammals are warm-blooded
but they don't share a warm-blooded
common ancestor
so it's a functional question it's not a
phylogenetic question when you say are
bees fish
it sounds like a phylogenetic question
and then bees can't be fish for the
purpose of some law it may be a
functional question which is why we're
getting the confusion do we have any
idea what the question was
what what question was why courts were
charged with figuring out whether bees
were a fish for the purpose as i told
you i don't remember anything about this
all right so if it's an endangered
species question the court may just
simply be understanding that whatever
defined them or defined the protected
group meant to protect
uh some habitat that included bees or
something and they're not really saying
anything about bees being fish and it
just seems strange yeah now i
used to be so so so good at powerpoint
and now i can't figure out how to make
it do what i want i would like to show
if i can get there
this
all right well while heather is
fiddling about here fiddling about yes
um
the wealth of pacific northwest drowns
the
a clade a phylogenetic clade is any
anything that falls off the tree of life
with a single snip
um a student of mine figured out that
that was the way to explain this after
we had explained to him
how to how to do the
um the phylogenetic work so the idea is
the way you can test whether or not a
cat is a fish is if i clip the
phylogenetic tree so that everything
that i believe is a fish so that both
sharks and salmon fall off cats fall off
inherently which is also why
uh
apes are monkeys it's not right to say
that's an ape and not a monkey all apes
have to be monkeys and the reason is
because if we clip the tree of life so
that all the monkeys the new world and
the old monkeys old world monkeys fall
off together all the apes will fall off
together too they are simply on that
branch
yep
so there's there's a lot to do here and
i'm thinking a future
uh a future curriculum i mean like this
sure used to teach this all the time um
but i'm not finding the clean and simple
without any setup uh
visuals to show so let's just let's move
on from there at this point
uh no bees are not fish but it's not a
sign of ridiculousness that the
california court uh
declared what they did yeah though it
may be right it's not inherently it's
not inherently insane it is
phylogenetically insane
right but the phylogenetic insanity is
not inherently at odds with what the
legal structure is trying to do yeah
right
watched brett's interview with garrett
vandenbush
sounded important but at least 20 went
over my head very frustrating could you
do a van bush and weinstein for dummies
and actually there's another question at
the bottom here uh
can you in the simplest possible terms
explain vanda bush's predictions so you
want to just try to i actually haven't
listened to your conversation yet i've
listened to the original one but
let me say a few things yeah one
um
uh a his english is phenomenal so this
is not a language issue this is a
complexity of belief issue
garrett is very difficult to understand
his belief is partially
standard and partially not he has a
fixation on innate immunity which i
believe is actually um his focus there
is correct but because what he believes
is a bit heterodox
it's um
you know it's hard to say whether it's
accurate right his focus on innate
immunity is really important we under
focus on it and part of the point was
it wasn't that the young
were unprotected from cova they were
protected by their youth they had innate
immunity
their youth protected them because in
youth in innate immunity is stronger and
acquired immunity is not as strong and
covet is best dealt with sorry's cov2 is
best defended off by innate immunity
right right and there's some interesting
and i believe there's a huge topic here
there's some interesting transition from
robust innate non-specific immunity to
specific immunity right adaptive
immunity over time right which in the
case of covid meant that the the elderly
were very vulnerable because they had
lost their innate immunity and hadn't
learned anything about fighting covid
um
so
i will say in general what garrett is
getting at
garrett's overarching so garrett has a
couple points one of them is standard
which is that mass vaccinating into the
face of an active pandemic is an insane
thing to do
because you are effectively creating a
gain of function experiment by virtue of
exposing a pathogen that is actively
circulating to
a
[Music]
seamless set of tests that it can
learn one by one in other words in a
mass vaccination scenario you have
people at every level of immunity from
uh
none
to
my immunity after my vaccination has
fully developed
right and so the point is every stage in
there is the next lesson for a pathogen
trying to overcome this particular
vaccine's induced immunity
so
vaccinating into the face of a pandemic
doesn't make sense because you're
creating you're creating uh the recipe
for
uh variants that escape the immunity
that you're creating and that's part of
his model that's standard actually
yes well that's standard these vaccines
which aren't really vaccines these
transfection agents
are
particularly bad to do that with because
they are particularly narrow right
nearly targeted narrowly targeted
uh a single epitope and so
that
created a recipe for disaster which
will have driven the evolution of
variance now the other part of his model
so you get the
the the idea also of a narrowly targeted
vaccine or vaccine-like thing
um
being a even worse thing to do to to
deploy in a pandemic is also
not that not really outside of the
bounds of um
vaccinology and and immunology thinking
at least until this era right now right
like he's
with that he's still not stepped outside
of anything that five years ago
most vaccinologists or immunologists
would have agreed with right right okay
so um
his predictions and i don't i don't want
to
cover all of them but the major
predictions are
this mass vaccination campaign will
drive the evolution
of increased transmissibility
it will drive the evolution of a
proliferation of variants both of those
things appear to have happened
he also predicts that it will drive the
increase in virulence which is the
destructive tendency of the virus
and i believe this is not fully borne
out yet
may never be but
oh and the last thing hope not is
his prediction that the virus will be
driven towards the young
right that it basically would be driven
towards
um
populations who are dependent on innate
immunity
and uh i believe we have seen
some evidence of this
so anyway
his his
thinking is very challenging some of
it's heterodox some of it is
standard and still not acknowledged
which is so odd yes um
but anyway uh don't feel bad that you
had trouble following it it's uh it's
it's a perspective that's well worth the
investment but it really is an
investment to to understand it
yeah
okay a couple more
couple more kobe questions um
i i don't think we can say much about
this first one but i'll read it
my mate 33 died january 22nd with blood
clots brain and cerebral hemorrhage
tested positive for kova two days prior
and recently got vaccine autopsy yielded
an unusual reaction to covid parentheses
cytokine storm
can you help make sense of this
um
yeah a little bit um
certainly there is a great deal of
interest in heterodox medical circles
about
blood clots and
hemorrhaging
and these vaccines yeah very unusual
blood clotting has been seen
there is an overlap
between the pathology of covid and the
um the so-called vaccines which is spike
protein
um
and
there's
potentially
you know the hypothesis which we've uh
explored here
which has to do with the damage to
tissue
um as a result of transfecting
cells
with uh
[Music]
we don't you don't say which vaccine but
likely mrna vaccines that have been
we now know
stabilized with pseudo-uridine making
them very durable but that those cells
will be read by the immune system
as virally infected cells and destroyed
and depending upon where in the body
that would happen uh it will do damage
to tissues and depending upon how vital
those tissues are it
can be fatal also potentially
involved in the blood clotting issue you
know if it's
circulatory vessels for example it
wouldn't be surprising to see
clots
arising
yeah um i think we probably should have
started by just saying um condolences
that's
absolutely terrible and uh
there's of course
nothing
comforting to say but uh
but we can imagine how terrible that is
dean
one more code question before a few
that aren't
most if not all of my triple vaxxed
friends recently got bad cases of coven
most if not all of my unvaxed friends
myself included either never got covered
or had it very mild
coincidence or is there something to
this
so i think some of the answers related
to what you were just talking about yeah
that i mean it turned as it turns out
it's not just the spike protein in cysco
v2
that's it's pathogenic to humans but the
spike protein definitely is and it's a
big piece of it and we know that the
mechanism of action of the mrna and the
and the adenovirus factor dna vaccines
like j and j
is that they produce they get your body
to produce the spike protein
and then hopefully get your
immune system to respond to the spike
protein and then know it when it shows
up later in the form of stereoscopy ii
but
more exposure to the thing that we
understand already to be pathogenic and
cytotoxic and all of this
may may well make
later exposure to the actual pathogen
worse and anecdotally this is not the
first time i've heard this anecdotally
we're hearing a lot of accounts like
this will we ever see data you know i i
wish that i weren't in the in
the position now saying oh god i've
heard that before people who are
vaccinated are getting it worse now and
people who aren't are either not
getting covered not vaccinated right
they're not getting covered or they're
getting mild cases one person after
another is telling me this whether or
not they know my personal status my
story anything i'm just hearing this a
lot
and i want someone to have actually been
capable in this system of collecting
data
that was blinded in all the ways it
needed to be blinded i don't even know
if that's possible anymore right now and
we have a system that can't tolerate the
answer and so if somebody collects it if
the answer is what it seems like it's
going to be yeah that answer won't be so
unfortunately we're stuck with anecdote
which is not um which is terrible we
don't want to be in that position but i
would also point out in addition
uh
we have the specter of potentially
antibody dependent enhancement yes and
uh original antigenic sin
which could explain this pattern and the
fact that we are not
that we are apparently still
um
[Music]
at least recommending
these same vaccines which have not been
updated for reasons that make no sense
yeah
and can track the immune system into a
narrow response in the face of a virus
that is evolving doesn't make any sense
could you get antibody dependent
enhancement as an additional mechanism
that would cause people who had been
vaccinated um to be more vulnerable yes
and more likely the more times they're
boosted
um potentially right and there's the
issue of
the
transfection
mrnas which have been stabilized to an
absurd degree
if they accumulate in macrophages and
those macrophages are attacked by t
cells because
they are now encoding a foreign antigen
um
that can have immunological consequences
that would make the disease worse so
there's all kinds of mechanisms and the
basic point is look this wasn't you know
the were the particulars easy to predict
no but
the idea that they were intervening in a
complex system in a way that invited all
sorts of potential um
unexpected
uh patterns of disease was clear from
the beginning it's what caught our
attention yeah now and it's
different from any other thing that came
before in part because it's complex
system into which we intervened with
tremendous hubris on top of complex
system into which we intervened with
incredible hubris and on and on but at
the you know at the very basic level we
have
a virus that did not exist in the wild
we created this virus
and the
only accepted mainstream
treatment that we are allowed to talk
about is a
kind of technology that is heretofore
not
not understood as to what all of its
effects might be so complex system
vaccination
like it's it's a beautiful beautiful
invention of humans as a way to
effectively trick your immune system
into thinking it's been exposed to
something uh in a non-dangerous form
that it hasn't actually been exposed to
yet it's amazing it's brilliant and what
we've got here is
a
is both a pathogen that no human or any
other organism on the planet with the
possible exception of some like some
ferrets in a lab i've ever been exposed
to before and now we've got a totally
new kind of experimental treatment as
well so how can we best predict the uh
the relationship between these two
things well given that neither of them
existed in the history of the world
before now of course everyone's kind of
scrambling to figure it out yep
and and
some people aren't scrambling to figure
it out
um but they are certain that what
they've got is the answer and they're
going to tell you that and if you don't
agree then that's on you yeah it's the
people scrambling to prevent anyone from
figuring it out that i'm most worried
about yeah
all right how far are we in zach
okay we're gonna do a few more we got a
lot of questions this week
um i'm tired of the phrase do your own
research or just google it to me that
sounds like a recipe for confirmation
bias yet it's the most common response i
get when asking for people's sources
please riff much love
um you know look
unfortunately we are stuck with what
you have to do
when your institutions have failed this
isn't supposed to be our job this is not
supposed to be happening on podcasts
right this is supposed to happen when
you charge an institution with the job
of figuring out what's true and you
granted the resources to do that and
that institution because the institution
survives if it does the job well
empowers the people within it to be
courageous and to say what must be said
and the stuff gets hashed out right
that's how it's supposed to happen
we let that system fail things that
i mean this is a caricature at one level
but things that made people money were
threatened by
systems that were free to discover the
truth and so they killed off the truth
seeking capacity of those systems and
now we are flying blind right with you
know a bunch of people who are basically
functioning on intuition and
superstition reinforced by google and
twitter and it's not working you know
big surprise
right of course it's not working the
right way to do this
is institutions that are structured to
actually reach answers and that when
they are vindicated over time that
results in those institutions being
empowered and when other institutions
say crazy stuff that turns out to be
wrong they
cease to be or they get modified so they
start doing it right this is supposed to
be happening in a framework where we all
understand that we are enhanced in our
safety when it works and that framework
does not exist you don't have a
newspaper you don't have a university
you don't have a cdc you don't have a
who and
you know yeah it's a disaster
we have to solve that issue and
you know if these institutions can't be
rescued which i strongly suspect they
can't be then they need to be replaced
next question
is there an evolutionary reason for
people to hear a story song or any other
narrative and care
for example elvis presley's in the
ghetto is a sad song but it's fictional
um
yeah
uh
what the exact reason is
we're gonna have to work at the level of
hypothesis yeah
um let's put it this way
i'm going to define empathy
in a way that many people would claim
i'm defining sympathy but it has to be
defined this way for reasons that matter
empathy is the capacity to figure out
what another individual will
think feel and do based on
you taking the data
of their experience and running it
through your own
calculator right in other words
if i you know
the person who wrote the question about
their significant other who died at 33
from covid and or
vaccine
injury
i can put myself
in their shoes and i can know an awful
lot about how they likely
felt based on the fact that anybody any
human being in that situation anybody
who's lost somebody can can imagine the
shock especially somebody young and
somebody very very close right
um
the thing about empathy though is
it is inherently indifferent to whether
or not the person
whose mindset you're trying to
understand is on your team or not right
you could empathize
with hitler in the bunker as the
russians are descending and you know why
he killed himself right because he
didn't want
to be exposed to the punishment for what
he had done right
so
obviously hitler is the ultimate other
team
right
but understanding his mindset is not
impossible right you can pretend it is
but it's not and you need to be able to
you know
you will much you will fight your
enemies much better if you understand
what's in their heads and how they feel
about it and you will do so based on
using your own mind and putting yourself
in their shoes
um
so here's the here's the point
that works
when
you have a lot of analogy with the
person right um so you know i know your
mind very very well for lots of reasons
we've been together forever there's that
but you and i you and i also grew up at
the same moment in history in the same
city traveling in the same circles and
schools and things and so the point is i
have an awful lot of information about
what's in your mind and there's a bunch
of stuff i can't get because i've never
been a woman and so how do i deal with
the stuff that i can't get or in the
case of a
you know uh
masai herdsmen how am i gonna get into
that person's mindset when i don't share
any history well i could read a story
about a maasai herdsman right or i could
read a story from the perspective of a
woman that would allow me to sort of
you know groove those particular thought
processes and then i'm not going to be
as good at it as i would with somebody
that i grew up with and you know is
you know male and
had you know similar experiences but
i'll be a lot better at it than i would
be naive right so basic point
punch line uh the answer to your
question is i think
in order to do the job well
you have to have the same shorthand in
your mind
that exists in the person's mind you're
trying to understand in other words
emotions are how we decide what to do
and what not to do
and
therefore we have stories that allow you
to teleport into a mind that isn't going
to be intuitive to you and if those
stories are really good right if they
have the verisimilitude to do the job
then the point is you've got to be run
through the emotional state as well as
just the calculations in order to see
why they feel this way and not that way
and so the point is it's not surprising
that a fictional story that is well
written
would teleport you enough into this mind
that you would have the experience as if
the mind was a real thing because you're
effectively running an emulation of it
in your own
yeah that's great that's great um
you're effectively running an emulation
one of the things i was prompted to
think while you were talking was
how many
features of humans have been invoked as
ah that's the difference that's what
makes us human you know famously it was
tool use for a while and then it was oh
you're making war
and it's been bipedality it's been
language uh and you know it i haven't
actually seen it written like it's
theory of oh it's been fire it's been
cooking right i haven't actually seen it
written that it's theory of mind because
anyone who thinks about theory of mind
carefully and doesn't have a completely
human bias
knows that other organisms have theory
of mind but we obviously have it much
much more developed but i'm wondering
if you know a it's not
it's not useful to look for the
character that makes us human that's not
that's that's not what humans is that's
missing the point of human at some at a
lot of levels
uh but that the extent to which we are
constantly running an emulation in your
language which is theory of mind ability
to understand that some other individual
with whom you're interacting can feel a
different way about a situation about
which you also have an opinion
is something that all humans
do
and that's what running an emulation is
and are
maybe just that and so obviously then i
don't actually know this particular song
the presley song in the ghetto
but
uh
music narrative theater poetry all of it
is can i see through their eyes nope
right can i can can i can i sit where
you're sitting can i walk in your shoes
can i understand you well enough to feel
what you are feeling and as you say
to some degree
even the end of life of adolf hitler is
understandable it's understanding and it
is completely different from saying
how i feel for him right no don't you
dare don't you dare do you dare feel for
that man
at that moment right you know maybe as a
five-year-old
um but uh
the the emulation that we run is
we do it far more
and far more complexly and far more
frequently than the other organisms like
parrots and crows and elephants and
dolphins and
chimps
and baboons who have theory of mind now
there's um
there are two two final points on this i
think one
it is surprising how well
you can do this with an animal
uh that you know
right like not a species but a pet right
well you know you can you can work
backwards if you have known you know
many cats right you can sort of get a
sense for how a cat might be a
circumstance
um you know it's vague and it's never
going to be at the level you can do it
with your own species but it is
surprising and it's also interesting how
important
uh you know i think
george schaller the
behavioral
the ethologist who
studied lions failed with great apes
jane goodall succeeded in part because
jane goodall broke the rule established
by men who had gone before her and
allowed herself to empathize
with her subjects rather than try to be
a robot and to see them through purely
objective eyes and the point was it was
actually also i think some one of the
big distinctions that both she made and
um and the gene altman who was working
at a similar moment but it was less
famous
and and altman was working on baboons
was actually we're going to look at
these as individuals we're not going to
kind of do this like it's a population
you know it's chips or it's baboons and
you know altman's
one of altman's significant
contributions which no one outside of
primatology probably knows who she is
but one of her significant contributions
uh to animal behavior is the concept of
the focal watch that when you're trying
to figure out what organisms do from a
scientific perspective
you go out and you have an animal and
you know you should know in advance you
know who they are and already know what
the population is don't say oh that
guy's doing something interesting i'm
gonna focal watch him
uh but you know watching one and then
seeing who interacts with them as
opposed to i'm just kind of gonna watch
the whole thing and see what happens
you're going to miss many of the details
that individuals go through right so
it's just it's another individual versus
population level difference and that's
one of the things i've been thinking
about this week so i think it's
yes well it also you know
population doesn't have a mind that you
can empathize with in the same way and
the individual does and you know the
farther an animal is from a human
um both in terms of you know an elephant
is fairly close to a human in terms of
what it is and does it's not at all
close to a human in terms of phylogeny
but nonetheless
you know the thing with chimps and
gorillas and to a slightly lesser extent
orangutans
is
your toolkit for understanding how an
individual would view something is
actually
you know it's
crude but it's on target right the
emotional range is there and the same
kinds of things uh result in the same
sorts of emotions so anyway you've got
to be very careful not to project
something that isn't there
but you know you know when your
cat is happy
right you can tell i mean your cat is
dismayed and when your cat is obsessed
with hunger fair facts
or squirrels right
and you know you've got to let yourself
test the hypothesis that yes actually i
am in that animal's
mindset okay but the other the other
sort of final point here is all right
you run an emulation of another person
let's say you sit down with somebody
you've never sat down with before in
your life but you know some thing about
them and where they grew up and what
they've done for a living and how large
a slice of history they've seen and all
of that right and you can do a certain
amount of emulating
okay now a friend somebody you've known
for years you've spent many many hours
in conversation on all sorts of topics
you can do a much higher resolution
version
than a family member you've known your
whole life an even higher resolution
version okay now
one of those people dies
right the person you've just sat down
with for the first time
you may feel bad that they're gone but
probably you don't have a rich enough
emulation that it persists but as you
get closer and closer as somebody
becomes more and more important to you
the richness of your emulation of them
goes up and up and up and
one of the
outgrowths of that is that when somebody
dies
your emulation of them is actually the
most real version of them in existence
right the memories of all of those who
knew them well in the various emulations
that they have running in their heads
that is not it's concrete it's real it's
neuronal activity and it's emulations
built
of actual experience with an actual
idiosyncratic person and so the i think
the person weirdly lives on in a very
real way
in your mind and i i take a kind of
comfort in this right so
my grandfather for example sometimes
i'll be looking at something that i know
either he saw
or he didn't see but would like to have
seen and would have had thoughts about
or maybe he would have been dismayed to
see it and i sort of feel like i'm
letting him look at it because i know
how he would react i'm letting the
emulation of him
interact with
the world since he since he died um
so anyway yeah that's great
it's a
interesting topic
two last questions and i apologize that
we have missed a number of good
questions here
i'm addicted to cold plunges after
listening to the hubermann podcast about
it have you two done cold plunges
get any cool riffs on temperature
regulation
so we have a lot to say about
temperature regulation i don't know if
if you have done cold plunges per se
there's a there's a korean women's spa
in the pacific northwest
that i have gone to that has a bunch of
hot pools also infrared saunas and steam
sun and dry sauna and in the room that
has all the hot pools of various
temperatures it also has a cold pool
and um so i've done it there a few times
it's been a long time since i've been
there but um
[Music]
it's kind of extraordinary and it it uh
it's ridiculously under selling it to
say it wakes you right up but uh it
it clearly resets some stuff and there
you know there's gonna i i've not seen
the superman or watch listen to the
superman podcast but i'd be interested
uh yeah there's something there around
heat shock proteins and there's
something there around just kind of a
reboot at a lot of levels around what to
expect from your world but there's also
uh sort of
giving your body things that are outside
of normal bounds so that it knows to be
on alert that actually you're going to
have to deal with things like this on
occasion yep i think that's good i have
done some uh
mostly alpine lakes
oh god you have yeah you've tried you
tried to kept well
in that case you're like yes but you're
coming out into air that's not that warm
still so i don't i'm not gonna do it
there yeah but it's you you love it yeah
so good i mean you know love it is a
weird thing to say
you have been enthusiastic about it i am
enthusiastic about it i think it's very
very good for you and i don't exactly
know why but boy do you feel alive after
you
uh
do
devin devin
after you've given into uh an alpine uh
like even in mid-summer you know at
altitude these things are very not
actually recommending diving into a body
of water that you haven't already sussed
out are you no okay i would yes
yeah but um but anyway yeah i think it's
you know i do sort of have the sense
okay with heat heat shock proteins with
cold
i sort of
hey there's this very interesting
phenomenon we've all experienced it
where uh you jump into some water it's
very cold
and then
30 seconds a minute later you feel like
oh that's pretty good i can stay in
right even though for that 30 seconds at
the beginning it was like ah it's
terrible right
so i think what that is
is we are total wusses over
the loss of heat to the environment
because our ancestors didn't have enough
to eat and losing heat is expensive
right it's just like burning money right
and so the point is you jump into the
water and it takes your capillaries some
time to shut down to basically shunt the
blood inward where it's not losing so
much heat to the environment once it's
done that the cost of you staying in is
lower but the discomfort is a measure of
your instantaneous costs and as you
first jump in those costs are really
really high
and so anyway as your capillaries shut
down
i sort of have the sense that it's like
wringing out a sponge and that actually
maybe that's good for you that actually
just you know
shunting all the blood out of your
periphery for 10 minutes and then
allowing it to re-perfuse
might have some uh value just in terms
of
flushing the system in some way yeah
okay
okay one last question
i've heard some people cite evolution as
a reason for not showering daily i.e it
removes body oils is that valid or just
plain gross or both
uh
i got a couple things to say go for it
um
yeah
i mean a i think there is something
marvelous about
um
daily
showers right that we there is something
very nice about these to be cleaner than
we would be right
um and you know
soap is necessary for certain stuff
probably we way overuse it absolutely
and that we disrupt the ecology on our
skin's surface
to a point that's not healthy
i i will also say hot water which i love
a hot shower but um lukewarm to cool
water without any soap isn't going to
wash away the oils right right right and
you know you use soap where you've
accumulated bacteria that smell
right and
by and large like how often does like
your upper arm get to a plate like
actually you don't probably don't need
soap there ever yeah and that's you know
that's the vast majority of your skin
that's going to be true for and that's
going to be where oils should be
accumulating and
no that's not gross that they accumulate
no it's not going to smell if you know
you get if you have you know your
natural skin oils accumulating on like
the back of your hand or your you know
upper arm and back your you know your
lower back or something um lower back
maybe maybe a intermediate stage but
there's a lot of places where you just
don't want you don't really need the
sound yeah almost ever i mean there'll
be exceptions but um
i would also say there's a game theory
problem here let's let's deal with
armpits
i think we're downright dumb
to be um tinkering with the
uh
the smell that comes from your armpits
this is some
ancient
animal communication mechanism we don't
know what it communicates we don't know
what role it plays
but the fact is you can't you can't
stand down as an individual certain
cultures
use far less deodorant than others and
the point is everybody is used to
everybody else and it's not abnormal but
if you're the one person in a culture
who isn't putting on deodorant it gets
noticed and
uh so anyway
i do think we we are
we have mess there's a lot of
chesterton's fence with stuff like uh
your underarms right and we mess with it
because it sort of seems like oh that's
off-putting uh let's do something about
it
um but
uh yeah anyway yep chesterton's
underarms you heard it here first
chesterton's underarm hair
hair now well the hair
clearly distributes the smell
um
you know by increasing the surface area
no absolutely okay okay well we'll end
with this brief vignette
um
which is that when we were first
traveling in central america uh i
thought okay while we're traveling
um
i'm not gonna shave in the ways that
i've shaved before and um why should i
and i found that it was so much harder
to to keep myself smelling at a level
that i wanted to grab myself crazy yeah
that i wasn't driving myself crazy
because we're in the tropics we're like
and it's like i'm no this is not an
affectation i'm not doing this for
fashion i'm shaving my underarms because
it's far easier to stay cleaning to stay
smelling clean to myself without having
to use a whole bunch of soaps and
lotions all the time not lotions but
yeah yeah so uh that that that was not
something i saw coming first we're
talking about when i was 20 but you know
i spent you know a half a summer going
like maybe i just won't do this like no
actually i'm happier this way
yeah yep
that makes sense but then chesterton's
underarm hair yes exactly that yeah so i
i have made the argument i don't know
that i believe it but it's it's a worthy
argument um you know would it alter the
divorce rate if people allowed their
underarm smell
to
be left visible is there some is there a
compatibility
metric i mean you know there's certainly
work that suggests that things that we
can't inherently detect we detect
subliminally and you know do say things
about
the chemistry of a match well i will say
this
if we were fighting and it seemed that
uh maybe we should split up
and i propose to you that maybe we need
to get a divorce and your response to me
was
how about you let your underarm hair
grow and let's see how you feel about it
then
that that wouldn't that wouldn't be a
selling point no that wouldn't be that's
not what i'm saying i'm saying people
get together who their
aversion to each other's smell might
have prevented an unfortunate
ah so before you know as part of the
sort of like let's assess let's talk to
your priest or your rabbi or whatever
let's also you're both gonna have to
grow if you've both shaved your
underarms you both got to grow this out
and just see if you can stay in each
other's smell for a month
there are certain tricks to figuring out
whether you're going to end up in a
messy divorce one is see if you can
share a tandem bicycle with somebody
okay two share a tandem kayak three
share a tent
um
and four i don't know try
not using deodorant for a week and see
if you hate each other
this list to be continued later i expect
i mean that's a pretty let's put it this
way any couple that gets through those
four things and they're they're still
into each other
it's probably worth a shot tandem
bicycle
tandem kayak tandem tent
and uh and don't shave your underarms
and live in close proximity for at least
a week yeah
right and no no deodorant yeah yeah yeah
oh and uh do a podcast together see how
that goes
yeah
all right
well um good on that note i think i wish
god it is so freaking wet here it's been
so wet for so long if you offered me a
ride on a tandem bicycle or a tandem
kayak and the weather were acceptable
for it be like let's go i'm gonna get
outside i need some sun it's almost by
the time we see you next guys we'll be
past the solstice we are we are in in
everywhere but in the northern
hemisphere the summer solstice it's
supposed to be the days are long it is
supposed to be warm and sunny and my god
is it not no it is not yeah it's very
soggy you know tandem snuggling under
blankets there you go
yes
all right uh we will be back
uh same time next week on saturday at
noon 30 pacific and until then be good
to the ones you love eat good food and
get outside
see ya
[Music]
you